buongiorno a tutti e grazie dell'invito
c'è qualcosa di estraneo in me che mi
rende un poco debilitato quindi farò la
presentazione da seduto un po come
succedeva tanti anni fa davanti al
caminetto con nonno che racconta le
storie ai ai nipoti
il virus che ho come partes tra estranei
in qualche modo ora in me che sto
combattendo a più non posso e merita
qualcosa di negativo ma c'è un virus
nella nostra società globale che non
agisce come un vulnus per la convivenza
dei popoli ma come diciamo un beneficio
un beneficio straordinario e questo
virus è quello della diversità culturale
un'estraneità vicino a noi una
estraneità di cui noi stessi siamo fatti
fatti siamo fare siamo fatti parte un po
come scriveva una celebre intellettuale
bulgara francese
anche noi siamo stranieri a noi stessi e
in questo nostro essere straniera noi
stessi ci rendiamo conto che facciamo
tante cose molto interessanti che
costruiamo dei capitali dei capitali
narrativi che vivono intorno a noi ogni
giorno insieme a capitali economici a
capitali infrastrutturale ma i capitali
narrativi visto che sono vissuti ogni
giorno e che in un qualche modo sono
fatti della stessa materia del nostro
respiro del tempo di cui forse non ci
rendiamo conto davvero ogni giorno beh
sono lì e ed è un bene io credo
valorizzarli questi capitali narrativi
che rendono conto che la nostra
esperienza quotidiana contemporanea ci
fa rendere protagonisti di storie
sconfinate laddove le fermate in cui in
un qualche modo sostarci riflettere
guardarci intorno fissare negli occhi
qualcun altro è fare azioni e sentire
emozioni e da qui scaturire
come sorgenti d'acqua fresca montane
storie questo è importante perché le
storie sconfinate ci permettono di
vivere insieme
il presente non mi ricordo chi me
l'avesse detto ma mi confidò la sua in
un qualche modo il suo fastidio nella
progressione che gli esseri umani va
verso il futuro costruiamo il futuro
speriamo nel futuro ma in verità il
futuro è un interrogativo noi parliamo
da partiamo da un presente
concentriamoci sul presente cosa
facciamo nel presente
ecco vivere il presente insieme in un
qualche modo racchiuso in questa foto
scattata a roma in cui 70 ragazzi legati
a con insieme sono andati alla camera
dei deputati ad assistere al dibattito
sulla legge per la cittadinanza sulla
proposta di legge sulla cittadinanza
l'italia legate alla campagna l'italia
l'italia sono anch'io per dare la
cittadinanza a chi è nato in italia da
genitori di origine straniera ancora
deve aspettare fino al diciottesimo anno
di età secondo lo ius sanguinis e non lo
ius solis come accade in negli stati
uniti avanti in altri paesi europei per
avere un diritto riconosciuto quello di
essere cittadino nel luogo in cui sono
sono andate vivere presenti insieme cosa
comporta
comporta innanzitutto qualcosa che è
raro ma straordinariamente potente al
giorno d'oggi emozioni
queste emozioni arrivano da cosa da
sfide il contatto con l'estraneità il
virus che vive in me e mi fa fare fatica
a fare questa presentazione a
raccogliere questa storia però mi porta
a sfidare una situazione una situazione
del presente che anche legata a chi in
un qualche modo è strano e diverso da
noi la diversità fa paura ma la
diversità è anche una risorsa la
diversità è anche un moto di curiosità e
innegabile che il termine il contesto la
cornice di questo sia una sfida una
sfida che però se vissuta nel modo
migliore può essere proposta come un
invito un invito a qualcosa di bello un
invito a qualcosa che ci porta
un'esperienza di conoscenza in più
un invito a non in qualche modo essere
recalcitranti davanti a qualcosa che non
sappiamo ma un invito a essere in un
qualche modo proposti verso e verso il
futuro
ieri abbiamo portato in una classe del
matilde di canossa un ragazzo che ha
vissuto l'emergenza della della libia
che dal ghana si è spostata nel paese
nordafricano e poi quando è scoppiata la
guerra è stato costretto a imbarcarsi
per lampedusa e in classe allora abbiamo
posto un nastro
nastro per per terra abbiamo invitato le
ragazze a togliersi le scarpe e a
sentire il freddo del pavimento ea
queste ragazze mss scalze sul pavimento
abbiamo detto volete restare qui partirà
il freddo cercare di andare avanti
loro hanno detto andiamo avanti così è
iniziata il racconto questa storia di
anthony che questo ragazzo che ha
testimoniato la sua esperienza in classe
ed è stato proprio un invito incarnato
realizzato per conoscere per conoscere e
quindi si è vinta una scommessa
no se vinta una scommessa ieri in classe
ed è una scommessa che dovremo vincere
ogni ogni giorno è una scommessa appunto
per trovare sempre nuove idee per
convivere perché io penso che non ci sia
ma è solo un'idea che vive per sempre
ed è per sempre quella buona ma le idee
in un qualche modo la storia
dell'umanità sono fatte per creare
sempre possibilità di ideare qualcosa di
nuovo
partiamo quindi da alcune azioni però
prima
sostiamo c tutto quello che ho detto io
credo che porti essenzialmente serenità
amicizia
fiducia
impegno e sono cose retoriche io sono un
folle avanti della retorica perché per
quale motivo perché io credo come nelle
leggende ci sia un elemento di verità
anche la retorica o ciò che definiamo un
retorico a un elemento di verità e
queste emozioni questi sentimenti sono
cose che ormai abbiamo alla costante
ricerca del nuovo di qualcosa di
eclatante sconvolgente abbiamo un po
emarginato nel luogo del della retorica
ma parlare di serenità amicizia fiducia
in kenya
no credo che siano delle cose che ancora
si sono sentite nel profondo attraverso
le relazioni diano
diciamo una sensazione di benessere
straordinario per raggiungere questo noi
crediamo che si debba parlare e
affrontare dal punti di vista diversi
creare raccontare cantare come è
successo a molti castro arab dei per
esempio fatto qui per fotografia europea
l'anno scorso viaggiare come è successo
per le ragazze delle mattine di canosa
che hanno vinto un premio plural plus
delle nazioni unite alliance of
civilizations nel novembre scorso
volare come fanno dei ragazzi che nelle
periferie di di reggio e saltano da un
un edificio all'altro nello sport del
parkour
tutto questo per scoprire dei dettagli
delle storie dei capitali narrativi
queste foto ne abbiamo scattate nelle
nostre attività e queste storie che
arrivano sono storie legate a semplice
azioni di me ti stai culturale o come si
dice in gergo tecnico anche di diversity
advantage come la diversità è risorsa
beh sono esempi semplici quelli che
provo a presentarvi rapidamente perché
scaturiscono dall attività quotidiana
che facciamo con ragazzi di origine
italiana il che vuol dire origini
macroregionali perché anche italia in se
stessi intrinsicamente a una varietà di
ricchezza interculturale straordinaria
passando andando da palermo a bolzano e
ecco i ragazzi di origine di origine
straniera
la prima storia che voglio raccontarvi è
quella dei money insieme reporters che
un gruppo qui voglio prendere la storia
di jessica e ada che sono la prima a
destra ad jessica è l'ultima sinistra è
un intervista che siamo andati a far a
parma ho voluto mettere questa foto
pensando anche a giorni in un qualche
modo che che avrebbe fatto un intervento
qui questo uomo al centro pier cavezza
esiliato politico del congo è dovuto
scappare in italia perché
si batteva per il diritto all'educazione
tante minacce di morte ed è arrivato a
parma abbiamo portati buonissime
reporters ad intervistarli insieme qui
ci sono anche alessia and his ma ho
voluto raccontare la storia di jesse che
ha da perché loro hanno in qualche modo
partecipato a un corso che facevamo un
insieme di giornalismo interculturali
sono appassionate in un qualche modo
sono qui a testimoniare questa passione
quest'impegno che che hanno poi le loro
storie particolare perché de sica tutti
familiari con la cittadinanza italiana è
solo lei in famiglia è l'unica senza
cittadinanza italiana ha da invece non
ce l'ha ancora fatto dieci anni quasi
diplomata ed è un problema perché in
qualche modo
a difficoltà anche vista la crisi ad
avere un percorso lavorativo perché è
sempre costretta e meccanismi legati ai
permessi di soggiorno per cure sono un
po delle contraddizioni che noi
nonostante una storia simile vediamo
agire sotto traccia nel nostro nel
nostro paese senza rendersene veramente
punto la storia di merger i maggiori la
conosciamo in un laboratorio di
educazione interculturale a scuola lo
scaruffi e si appassiona fa tantissime
attività giornalistiche anche per
esempio quel premio borzano del borsani
dei teatri ed è diventata una firma di
punta dei mondi insieme reporters
scrittrice c'è tra voluto mettere lei
perché lei ha viaggiato e partecipato a
questo evento europeo degli european
journalist for diversity dove anche
marina era era era era presente emergere
ha lavorato con una giornalista bulgara
per raccontare il rapporto tra sport e
intercultura a bordo quindi
un'esperienza sicuramente utile poi c'è
la storia di alessia alessia l'abbiamo
conosciuta in un laboratorio
interculturale a scuola a seconda del
canossa si è appassionata e ed è stata
una delle piacevoli sorprese con
l'iniziativa che abbiamo fatto con i
nuovi reggiani e pagina del resto del
carlino lei ha scoperto che nella sua
classe alla sua scuola c'erano due
ragazze convocate dalla nazionale
italiana di origine tunisina non ancora
diciottenne quindi senza cittadinanza
che in quanto italiane nata a santa
maria ospedale di reggio emilia vanoni
italiane convocati alla nazionale non
potevano partecipare alla nazionale di
pallamano e quindi questa storia in data
in prima pagina sul resto del carlino
alessia 15 anni direttore del giornale
avrebbe detto a bello la faciliterà
scrivere però sento troppo piccola non
non era possibile e alessia è ancora in
prima linea raccontare a provare a
raccontare quello che succede
nell'italia che cambia la storia dita
ancheta abbiamo conosciuto a scuola poi
è venuto a fare un corso di sempre di
giornalismi per culturale mogli insieme
ha incrociato l'esperienza anche di 18
25 organizzata da per fotografia europea
dove in un qualche modo racco si prova a
fare educazione alla fotografia scuola
di fotografia con giovani qui reggiani e
attraverso tutti questi percorsi è stato
uno dei fotografi principali che ha
partecipato a inside out quindi questa
grande processo artistico di performance
ideata da jay all'artista francese che
ha vinto il premio the licks 2011 2011
penso si è e niente questa è diciamo
così la l'installazione che potete
vedere qui di fronte ai ai musei civici
in cui si sono in qualche modo verso i
ritratti di tanti cittadini reggiani che
hanno messo la faccia per dire sì alla
cittadinanza per i giovani nati in
italia da genitori stranieri età è stato
uno dei dei fotografi
ho messo questa foto perché li ha
scritto chance c'è una chance per tutti
se in un qualche modo sono valorizzate
quelle risorse competenze che ognuno di
noi ha risorse che per esempio hayat
alessandrina di alessandria d'egitto ma
reggiana a mette nel suo essere
attivista partecipante alla vita
politica egiziana
lei ha creato un gruppo di giovani che
amano l'egitto ed a reggio emilia ha
messo su insieme un gruppo per fare in
modo che il maggior numero di egiziani
possibile votasse alle elezioni
sulla caduta di legate alla caduta di
mubarak e alle elezioni del presidente e
morsi al di là del diciamo così
contingenze politiche le scelte di
ognuno però il fatto di attivarsi a
reggio emilia per sviluppare questa
passione per il paese
di origine dei genitori è un messaggio
di partecipazione di risorsa
straordinario pensate se questi ragazzi
potessero mettere questa partecipazione
questo sguardo nuovo nella nella
politica del nostro paese che significa
nelle pensare il futuro del nostro del
nostro del nostro paese partendo da
azioni quotidiane
poi c'è la storia di ismani da isma eni
da due sorelle di origine pakistan e
questo è un bel esempio di diversity
denti perché perché sempre dalle
attività legate alle scuole le abbiamo
ne abbiamo scoperte eni da ci ha aiutato
tantissimo nelle traduzioni
dall'italiano allure lei possiede molto
bene lourdes non avremmo potuto tradurre
tante cose da italiano a lourdes senza
valorizzare la competenza linguistica e
tanti di origine straniera hanno qui in
italia pensate nelle nelle aree
commerciali delle aziende cosa vorrebbe
dire in qualche modo avere due persone
che possiedono due universi simbolici e
due e due linguaggi la facilità di
relazione e quello che potrebbero aprire
in termini proprio i nuovi orizzonti
banalmente commerciali
marco polo e la grandezza rinascimentale
dell'italia è nata semplicemente dal dal
commercio in un qualche modo è perché
non non imparare questa lezione della
storia e legarla ai ragazzi di seconda
generazione che qui vivono qui hanno una
straordinaria competenza need is ma
invece è lei sa fare lei è molto bene
el.en
io non so fare le troviamo tra gli
italiani qui italiane qui in quanti
sanno fare le alzate la mano secondo me
non tanti come si fa la pasta come si
fanno i ricami eccetera eccetera
lei sa fare questo e nel parco ogni
estate
proviamo a coinvolgere le persone del
quartiere per avere dei tatuaggi
all'henné e per spiegare cosa
significano poi c'è la storia di san
la storia di sun che in un qualche modo
la vedrete incarnata qui davanti a breve
e la storia di una ragazza che porta al
velo e che è che fa il pop
lei ha partecipato al multicultura razze
dell'anno scorso
e ha nel suo canto nelle sue però parole
una forza di andare al cuore delle
questioni e di unire il valore dei
diritti al valore delle storie per
rendere in qualche modo davvero
sconfinate lascio diciamo così qualcosa
in sospeso perché la vedrete qui
attraverso la sua fair fano ma se chiudo
con questo mi alzo se vengo chiamata
l'ambulanza
c'è una parola più ormai ci siamo
stancati tutti di ascoltare che hai
presi dal greco crisis che significa il
potere di distinguere scegliere mi siedo
questa parola può assumere due
significati quello di disgrazia è quello
di opportunità l'incontro con la
diversità produce in ciascuno di noi una
crisi inevitabile messi in discussione
di quello che si conosce fino a quel
momento
ma l'incontro con la diversità
inevitabile da sempre oggi processo ogni
processo acquista toni più vividi perché
gli incontri si moltiplicano e le
combinazioni tra diversità pure ciascuno
di noi ha sempre comunque la possibilità
di scegliere soprattutto oggi è
importante che si sente responsabile
delle sue scelte
puoi scegliere di vivere l'incontro con
la diversità con un adesivo disgrazia e
quindi collaborare questa scelta
erigendo dei muri
oppure puoi scegliere di viverlo come un
opportunità interessandosi anche a chi
pensa diversamente oa chi parla mangia
prega si veste in un modo diverso
non ci sono buoni o cattivi ci sono
porte che si chiudono pure porte che si
aprono mondi che si difendono oppure
mondi e si contaminano per questo
costruiamo e vi auguriamo buone con
contaminazioni questo è un testo scritto
e condiviso con noi quello stati moglie
insieme da da chiara greco la nostra
collega che è che abbiamo letto a
chiusura di primavera senza razzismo
l'evento che facciamo con le scuole ogni
21 di marzo per celebrare la ricchezza
della diversità e per combattere
razzismi e discriminazioni
io vi ringrazio molto dell'attenzione